nobody knows
much about this jordan peel film oh yeah
and i'm very excited yeah and i also
love that i don't know
what's happening and that uh
very little has been said and to me
that feels
um it's such a it's a compliment but
jordan peele is really good at it i
think jj abrams is really good at they
almost have like an old-fashioned sense
yeah
it's ringling brothers and barnum bailey
like wait you're gonna we got something
for you but you have to come into the
tent when the show happens and then
you'll be blown away and we have a
culture that gives away way too much
before things happen now i can't tell
you my kids always want to watch the
trailer to a film before they watch the
film yes and they have them on netflix
and say look let's watch the trailer yes
and they basically want to watch
they want to know what citizen kane is
about and they want to know what rosebud
is before we watch the movie yeah like
no
no just experience it but it's
culturally i mean my five-year-old does
that already he's like let me watch the
trailer i'm like what's happening
it's good just trust me this is a movie
i'm in yeah
what are you doing i was nominated for
an oscar for this film let's check out
the truth see the trailer yeah
but it is it's crazy it really is yeah i
agree with all of that like there's
something about
um the way like trailers and all these
things like pull us out of like
experiencing what is happening right in
front of you and i do respect deeply
what jordan's doing which is like
bringing it back to like remember when
we were like there and paying attention
at the same time
and like experiencing something together
i really think that was like the draw of
top gun for me like like i i people the
people went bonkers for that you can
you know come up with a bunch of like
conclusions about what that was but like
for me it was just like oh i forgot we
can all show up here know nothing about
how this is gonna go
and just
communally watch this and like be
present with all of it with each other
yeah on this ride i thought that was
really one thing i wasn't expecting was
uh at the top of the movie wait a minute
don't spoil it this isn't a spoiler okay
it's not a spoiler i have a small child
so i can't get out to a movie like what
you guys are talking about i'm not going
to ruin the movie okay i'm not going to
ruin this i don't like that look in your
head i know i don't believe you you have
a look on your face i was shocked that
he doesn't fly a plane at all at one
time not once yeah it opens with him in
a hospital and he's no longer allowed to
fly he has no inner ear infection and no
legs no legs
um and uh but it's a lot of him thinking
about flying yes while he eats pudding
you know what i will say i
love first of all tom cruise is my age
and so a huge thing for me was frankly
staying in the theater because he looks
amazing
and he's running around and jumping into
a cockpit and
making out with his beauty and i was
just like yes
we're still here
i
know trust me i
my powers of self-delusion are so
powerful
that when tom cruise is doing these
things i'm able to
say yes
i'm still attractive
[Laughter]
to jennifer connelly people like what
jennifer connolly doesn't care about you
and he brought you in no he brought me
in i did think there was part of it
which is and brad pitt too i'm the same
age as these guys
and so i know that they are genetically
very different from me i accept that and
they go to a gym
uh and probably eat properly yes there
are some differences but still i'm i
root for them to keep
uh making movies
and uh getting you know
you know having a make-out scene or a
sex scene because that's your shirt's
off chest yeah
sweaty yeah i'm down for it too i'm
totally fine it means my penis will work
again
did i
but when i see that film i know it can
happen
you see that you're eating pudding and
go yay
[Laughter]
just crushing viagra into my pudding
something will give it's got to
something will kill
move down it move
don't wanna maybe if you stop yelling at
it yeah yeah yeah
uh anyway that took a turn